bueno abril ya sabemos que ha sido el
mes más letal desde el inicio de la
pandemia con una media de 2.000 muertos
por vías y con picos diarios incluso de
más de 4000 además hay un dato también
muy duro en los primeros cuatro meses
del año han muerto más personas que en
todo 2020 por causa del coronavirus
brasil también ha cuadriplicado el ritmo
de los fallecimientos
el año pasado necesitamos 149 días para
registrar los primeros 100.000 muertos
los últimos de mil muertos se han
registrado en tan solo 36 días por todas
estas razones los expertos advierten que
no es el momento de retomar la
normalidad recordamos que brasil sigue
sin una política nacional de cuarentena
y que el presidente de jair bolsonaro se
opone a cualquier forma de restricción
de la movilidad de los ciudadanos
concretamente en río de janeiro donde me
encuentro ahora se van a reabrir otras
actividades a partir de mañana a las
playas ya funcionan de lunes a viernes y
esto preocupa a los expertos
bueno varía pero también cuéntenos por
qué decidió suspender la importación de
la vacuna rusa no necesariamente justo
tener ahorita más vacunas en estos
momentos para poder hacer frente a esta
tercera ola de contagios
en términos de salud cuál es la
condición y por qué se suspende la
importación entonces el sputnik ve de
hecho los gobernadores de 14 estados
federales esperaban podría importar 30
millones de dosis de la sputnik ve sin
embargo brasil tiene una agencia de
nacional de vigilancia sanitaria que
considerada una de las más exigentes del
mundo y el pasado lunes esta agencia la
anvisa dijo que los productores de la
vacuna rusa no presentaron la
documentación suficientemente clara que
no hay transparencia y que exactamente
este vector el adenovirus que lleva el
coronavirus dentro del cuerpo para
producir la respuesta inmune se está
replicando sin control pues es válida
saccone nuestra corresponsal en río de
janeiro con la información